Good Morning John! We're back! It seems like
it's been a really long time since there's
been a Vlogbrothers video. I miss this! I
skip one day, and it's like Vlogbrothers withdrawal.
So I'm going to start out this video by asking
you John, what did you get for Christmas?
So that I can then tell you all the things
that I got for Christmas. One of them you
can see a sign of, but it's not actually there.
And what's the sign? There it is! What is
is? It's a- it's a light! And that means that
I can now make videos at night time! Which
is good, because in the winter, in Montana,
nighttime starts at four. John also got me
this book, that's about t-shirts, and politics,
and world-trade. But this is a good book to
have, because apparently John and I are now
in the t-shirt business and we want to be
in the t-shirt business in a way that does
not help to increase world suck. Speaking
of t-shirts, any of you who got vlogbrothers,
DFTBA, nerdfighters, t-shirts for christmas,
or just bought them for yourself, we want
to see them. We want to see you wearing them!
And we may put them on our website. But please
send them to hankandjohn@gmail.com with shirt
in the title.
What else did I get? What else? Katherine
got me this bag. It's a good bag. And it was
wrapped and I was like "this is really heavy!"
And I unwrapped it, and I was like "Oh, this
is a really nice bag, but it's really heavy!"
And then I opened it. And inside were all
of my favorite guilty pleasure foods, including
fudge rounds, or which there are like-there
are like only two left. One. There's one left.
This is from my mom. I love that my mom still
gets me toys for Christmas. I also love that
I still like getting toys for Christmas. That-It's
nice.
Other guilty pleasure food. I know, it says
that it's organic and all-natural and everything.
Why is it a guilty pleasure? Well, look, cause
it has 62% of your daily sodium in it. It's
like just, a can of ocean.
My mom also got me this. And it came with
this. And I was like "okay, so this is...
and this... you hit them together and it makes
a noise. So it's some kind of musical instrument."
And then when I was talking to my mom later,
I was like "I'm not entirely sure what that
thing is, but I like it! It's fun." And she
was like "Hank, it's a cheese cutter." And
I was like "Oh, I thought that every time
I hit it, someone said a prayer or something"
It's like a Tibetan prayer cheese cutter.
I got a key chain, which I know isn't a big
deal, but it's the first time in our lives
that Katherine and I have had a separate key
chain. And it also comes with this, which
is a key which has been cut into a bottle
opener. Which is freaking awesome! Katherine
got it at an etsy store.
And then I got a bunch of science fiction
novels, which is really all I want! Oh, and
my favorite thing about the lighting kit is
the instruction manual. It's one page, and
it has helpful tips like "please avoid the
tumble of the lamps!"
And finally, let me show a video that Hank
Green made about a year ago. You know, Hank
Green, this guy.
Here are my two brain crack ideas from so
far this trip: a housed camera that you can
like clamp to a tree or a pole or something,
that takes time-lapsed pictures of whatever
you want to take time-lapsed pictures of.
Yes my friends, I wanted that to exist, and
now- AHH! it broke. Totally it's the thing
I wanted! It also doubles as the nerdiest
scepter of all time. Da-ta-da-da-I am the
king, the king of the nerds! It's articulated
here, but it's a little loose right now. It's
okay buddy, you're okay. And those are my
Christmas presents from this year, 2010.
John, I want to know, all of what you received,
and nerdfighters, you can tell me as well.
But I also want to give you nerdfighters a
present. What do you like about this. I'm
pointing at me, but I mean me and John. Let's
say this last year, in 2010, what is it that
you have most enjoyed. We've done a bunch
of different stuff. Every year we sort of
restructure what we, John and I, do here on
the vlogbrothers channel. And John and I are
in the midst of talking about that with the
two of us, but really, it should be a conversation
between all of us. Tell us what you like about
us, and what you would like us to do with
our time, and your time, here on this channel.
We've got some ideas that I know you will
be excited about. But I love ideas, and I
hope that you have more and then we can do
more awesome things in twenty-eleven. Two-Thousand-and-eleven.
Two-eleven. I'm not sure how to say that.
I'm fairly sure that it doesn't matter though.
John, I will see you on whatever day you come
back on.